discussion of a bunch of folks who I've
been carefully observing the debates
this first one in particular I am your
moderator I'm Katherine Rangi ward with
reason magazine and i'm joined by folks
from roll call christian science monitor
and think progress you want to introduce
yourselves briefly we can start with
roll call hi i'm david hawkings i'm the
editor of the CQ roll call daily
briefing in Washington Christian Science
Monitor hi I'm Liz Marlantes I'm a
political reporter for The Christian
Science Monitor and I blog at the
monitors political blog DC decoder and
think progress hey i'm ian millhiser and
i edit Think Progress justice so what
did you guys think Ian give us your run
down well I think the big news to the
extent there was any news broken today
was the fact that Romney repudiated his
tax plan he's been running on this plan
for about a year now that has three
prongs its twenty percent cuts across
the board its revenue neutrality so that
up he wants to make sure that same
amount of revenue were getting now we
still get and then it's some unspecified
tax cuts that he wants to get rid of
although he refuses to tell you which
ones and that plans been maligned
because the math doesn't work on it and
Obama called him out today because the
math doesn't work on it and Romney
simply said well then that's not my plan
um Obama early and debate kept bringing
up this five billion dollar figure
that's the amount that all revenues we
lose from the twenty percent on cuts and
Romney said okay well then that five
billion dollar number that's not my plan
um and it's you know I think the
president might have been a little off
put by the fact that Romney repudiated a
plan that he's been running on for a
year but that's the news is that Romney
has repudiated a major part of his
policy what do you think Liz yeah I
thought Obama was definitely um thrown
off a little bit by that and and really
what was most striking to me about
Romney
it was how much he tacked to the center
which we haven't really seen him do that
much throughout this campaign I need to
a surprising extent everyone expected
him to run to the right during a primary
but he kind of stayed to the right even
after he you know won the nomination he
continued to really you know continue to
talk to the base it seemed throughout
most of this campaign and this was the
first time we really saw Romney come out
and embrace a more moderate image and
and kind of say you know all the stuff
you like about Obama I'm for those
things to an end and as Ian just said
the position he just took on his tax
plan although I don't know we'll see
what they are saying right now in this
bedroom and what they say going forward
in terms of whether he actually really
repudiated his plan or not but but um he
at least seemed to be saying you know I
I have a way to make this revenue
neutral it's not going to add to the
deficit I'm going to find enough
deductions that the upper income people
don't actually get a net tax cut and
even though he's again still not saying
what those deductions are specifically
he seemed to be implying tonight that
that if the math doesn't add up he maybe
wouldn't do it so that was a different
Romney than we've seen throughout the
entire campaign but probably one that's
going to be more appealing to two more
voters so we'll see what the ripple
effects of this will be mm-hmm what do
you say excellent point so far i would
say that as somebody who used to be the
tax editor @ CQ to enroll call and who
sort of thinks wonky most of the time to
me that wasn't the news so much as the
atmospherics and i think undeniably you
have to say the atmospherics went to MIT
Romney the president seemed to his sort
of well what we watch in Washington
every day and those of us who go to the
press briefings and see him at the
podium all the time that sort of
deliberate ponderous professorial
approach made him look I think kind of
lost in the weeds a little bit and
Romney was was totally on his game from
them from the very first answer came
right out of the box and immediately
started talking about real people that
he'd met in Dayton and Denver I'm
knocked the president I thought on his
heels from the start
than ever even unleashed a forty seven
percent comment we never even heard the
number forty-seven percent all night
long the tax thing I think clearly
rattled him and he never really
recovered and I think probably what
we're all going to wake up to tomorrow
morning I our water cooler discussions
and cable TV coverage that says that
Romney came in with the most gain and he
gained it you know reason actually had a
drinking game that we posted on our
website that included the forty-seven
percent figure we were like so confident
that that was going to happen it seemed
like a good way to get smashed by the
end of the debate uh luckily we did also
have I think that heartwarming personal
anecdote American Civic and he only
wanted to use the number 47 tonight was
Romney at one point he was talking about
like training programs or something I
we've got 47 of them and I thought he
use that number voluntarily that's it
well that definitely would have
qualified for the drinking and so that
that look of it fine I mean I was struck
by by the I mean obviously this sort of
pon de tree on this will also be that
layer as moderator was kind of a mess
and couldn't couldn't keep a hold of the
the candidates but I was struck by his
sort of ongoing theme or his desire to
make the candidates explain the ways in
which they're different oh there's a
moderator in that debate I know right
you can really see you who knows what
that guy was up to that somebody on
Twitter said they thought he was
watching an episode of Homeland on his I
had at one point so Amy and I just don't
want to miss his his stories as my
grandma says uh but you know this idea
that somehow the candidates needed
prodding to differentiate themselves
that they needed this sort of extra push
to say you know I'm different than that
guy you should vote for me because of
our differences struck me is kind of
weird and you know obviously as a as a
writer here at at reason I'm tempted
always into the kind of pox on both
their houses approach and sort of this
idea that there that there isn't that
much daylight between the two candidates
you know did anybody have kind of
thoughts about whether they did
successfully differentiate themselves I
mean there was a lot of you know know
know my opponent has has taken me to
making a stronger statement than am you
know Romney kept saying yeah I actually
don't want to cut taxes and I actually
don't want to is some of the kinds of
things you'd expect Republican to say he
wasn't he was backing off of them was
that did anybody else kind of know I'm
with you I thought that the paradox was
that it seemed almost an antic at the
start that lera was saying so the two of
you disagree on the role of government
you to disagree on how to get to the
deficit this is stuff that anybody who's
been paying a really any attention at
all for the past year they know the
basic answers but as you suggested right
at the start Katherine this one of the
stories of the night was how for
whatever reason that discussion prompted
Romney to move toward the center and to
point out ways in which he and the
president agreed on some things and
actually Obama a few times said the same
thing so it sort of muddy the waters i'm
not sure if ultimately what these
debates are all about are trying to get
those five or six percent of the people
who still haven't met their mind off the
dime i'm not sure on the substance of
the matter whether they got anything to
hang their hats off but i think that
does romney a potential potentially a
lot of good because he really the Obama
campaign's whole strategy in a way has
been to say to the American people okay
look we know things aren't that great
but you can trust me I'm safe I'm not
going to do something scary and dramatic
that is going to you know change
Medicare or whatever you know you can
you can trust that if you stick with me
nothing is going to fall off the cliff
and they've been trying to portray
Romney as you know radical queuing to
the right you know not as trustworthy
and I think Romney's whole strategy
tonight clearly was to say no no I'm
just as safe as he has all the things
you like about him I'm gonna stick with
those things there's nothing really that
different about me when it comes to you
know whole range of things but I know
more about the economy and I know how to
create jobs and that was kind of the
message he kept hitting over and over
and over again and I think it was an
effective one tonight so I agree that
Romney strategy was to spend an hour and
a half blurring the differences between
him and the president and then the
question is whether an hour and a half
spent blurring those differences can
cover up a year and a half
accentuating really serious differences
I mean there are massive differences
between their tax plans that I got into
before their massive differences between
their health care plans you know Obama's
plan we know his plan to expand coverage
to about 35 million five million people
Romney's plan he wants to cut about 1.2
trillion dollars from Medicaid over time
he wants to voucherize Medicare this is
going to lead to I believe the estimate
i saw was about 20 million people who
currently have health coverage
eventually losing that these are big
differences and the question I think is
whether Romney buying one high-profile
event trying to paper over those
differences can overcome the negative
impression that I think many Americans
have developed over the last 18 months
and particularly you know there's going
to be I think the immediate spin coming
out of this debate is probably going to
be that romney won his energy level was
higher than Obama's definitely and
that's something that people respond to
but of course we're going to get fact
checks and there's when the press has a
day to kind of chew over a lot of what
they said sometimes the overall
impression can really change so we'll
see you did you have to say that he did
look if one of his goals mitt romney's
was to look to be the president's equal
or at least comparable pull that one off
I thought pretty well I think it's
pretty amazing when you see those close
shots of the two of them at the same
background no presidential seal on one
podium they looked you know I was have
to say that Mitt Romney is going to
probably come across looking as
presidential and is up to the job as
sort of reasoned and and serious as the
American public wants their president to
me so I thought in terms of that
atmospheric give the night to Romney in
terms of setting setting the bar for
himself of you know I need to look like
I deserve to be on this stage I deserve
to be standing next to the guy who's
already the president pull that off
which suggests that we're actually
operating with a kind of like
hilariously low bar right hey look both
of the guys on the stage at the end of
the nomination process for pride
looks like they could plausibly be
President like crazy we've done it but
but I actually I mean I do think will
obviously be having a spate of fact
checks afterward and you know maybe we
could just start with with Liz what do
you think the thing is you know not just
in terms of partisan but issues but in
terms of you know what is the one really
factually abominable thing that happened
in this debate oh gosh well I mean I
think the thing that is going to get the
most follow up questions is the back and
forth over Romney's tax plan because he
did seem to be shifting the the thrust
of what was understood to be his plan or
at least suggesting that his plan might
not be what we think it is if if the
numbers don't add up or something like
that I mean there's obviously going to
be a lot of back and forth about that in
the days to come and his aides are gonna
have to clarify he's gonna have to
clarify because it's not what we
understood it to be I mean Obama had a
pretty good line I thought he said for
18 months he's been running on this tax
man and now five weeks before the
election he says nevermind well you know
that there's going to be a lot of
follow-up about what exactly um you know
whether whether the wealthiest people
are going to get a tax break under
Romney's tax plan or not because pretty
much throughout this campaign the
understanding from the Obama campaign
and the Romney campaign has been that
the wealthiest Americans will get a tax
break and now tonight p over and over
again said no they won't so I think that
that will definitely be something that's
going to have to be clarified going
forward what i was saying i would say
absolutely that was number one probably
number two I think I'm still confused as
to where Mitt Romney wants us to think
about what he wants us to think about
these similarities and differences
between the Massachusetts health care
law and Obamacare it just seems like
he's really in some of the same sentence
is trying to kind of have it both ways
he didn't quite do what he did a week
ago when he when he said in an interview
on i think it was NBC he was asked for
some sign of of his compassion as a
governor or is it as a politician and he
cited the massachusetts health care law
then as soon as the cameras were off on
that interview that came out and told a
rally that obamacare was you know was
the devil's work and he
and repeal it tonight he seemed to
conflate those two things even in some
of the same sentences I don't think the
American people will buy just this
notion that well maybe it worked in my
state but it wouldn't work nationwide
that seems to be the distinction he's
drawing at this point so just for the
sake of bipartisanship now tell me the
biggest whopper that we got from Obama
or the biggest mischaracterization if we
don't want an actual fact check I mean
what do you think like aside from the
Romney hmm fudge what you know what was
Obama saying that people are raising
eyebrows butter should be raising
eyebrows about right now go ahead an i
mean i have to say that on both sides
and there were a lot of very wonky facts
being thrown around in this debate so i
don't want to necessarily give them both
a free pass but i think on both sides
there weren't too many things that
jumped out to me is oh that's a new lie
that I haven't heard before um with the
exception of Romney repudiating his tax
plan with you know we've all we've all
mentioned I think that um I agree with
David that there was a lot of attempts
to draw distinctions that don't make a
lot of sense um you know Romney's been
running on this line for a while where
Obamacare is awesome if a state
legislature passes it but it's terrible
if the federal government passes it and
there's maybe three people in the
country who actually care about
federalism and all of them are all
professors on the rest of us care about
results and so I don't think that one's
gonna work but I mean I you know on
other people tell me if you could take
it something but I can't think of a
particular whopper from Obama that
really stand out to me he did say that
he he has already proposed one true he
has already pushed through a trillion
dollars in cuts as part of the deficit
discussion I would say that's close to a
whopper he was sort of dragged kicking
and screaming to agree to that trillion
dollar in spending cuts as sort of the
only thing that was left when they did
the debt ceiling deal last summer this
is the so-called sequestration is across
the board cuts he says he was he's
already on
with those of course he's really not
he's trying as most members of Congress
are to get out from under that
across-the-board spending rubric by the
end of the year I also don't exactly
know maybe somebody who knows Romney
better than I do what the two trillion
and defense spending that the military
doesn't want what I don't is that that
seemed sort of out of the blue to me but
maybe that's not out of the book I mean
I'm certainly not an expert if there's
someone else to as they can jump in but
there's this kind of my understanding is
there's this ritualistic thing that
happens with defense appropriations
where the Pentagon asks for a certain
amount of money and then in order to
demonstrate that they support the troops
and love America and have flags on their
lapels Congress kind of ritual e gives x
percent more and because we're now
talking about debt deficit in a serious
way that strange ritual is being
questioned on the debate floor for the
first time but if people have more more
detailed analysis i'll be welcome you
know if i could go back to David's point
about the role that deficits played in
the debate on you know one thing I
thought was very disappointing is that
that conversation was held entirely on
the conservative turn on you know right
now we have very high unemployment and
right now we have very very low interest
rates the United States can essentially
borrow money for free and what the
economist will tell you when you have
high unemployment and you have very very
low interest rates is that the
government should borrow money and they
should stimulate the economy that's what
Obama did in 2009 it was the right thing
to do it's the reason why the United
States is now on the course of recovery
well many of our pure nations in Europe
or falling back into recession because
they didn't do that and I was very
disappointed that our political debate
on doesn't take that into account and
it's become who's going to cut more even
Obama knows better is talk about how
he's going to cut out more well
politically I think the deficit is one
of the few issues where at least going
into this debate Romney still had an
edge over Obama there weren't there
weren't many
issues but the deficit was maybe I think
the top issue that Romney had over Obama
in at least some polls i think it was
still double digits and so i think obama
probably correctly feels like he doesn't
really have room to maneuver on that
particular issue if he doesn't want to
open up a vulnerability and i actually
thought that was one of Romney's more
effective points hitting the president
you know he kind of he kind of really
got at the fact that some of the
spending cuts the president has held out
are pretty small potatoes that when he
talks about you know the tax breaks to
Exxon Mobil I thought Romney's were
joined her about you know comparing that
to the tax breaks he gave to green
energy was actually a pretty effective
one but it's not the tax cuts exxon
mobil that's the biggest part of obama's
plan to reduce the deficit it's getting
rid of the tax cut the bush tax cuts for
the people who are over 250 thousand
dollars you know if you look at where
our deficits come from they don't come
from obama's policies all of our
stimulus money has been spent there's no
new debt coming from that from that from
the stimulus the the Affordable Care Act
actually reduces the deficit and so all
of this comes from the bush tax cuts it
comes from the war in Iraq comes in the
war in Afghanistan it comes from
Medicare Part D which is a program i
support i just wish they paid for it
when george w bush signed that sign that
bill that's where our deficits come from
okay not not to get you all like horse
racing or you know like esthetics on you
in but like is it one thing people are
going to say about this debate that
obama weirdly didn't act like he had had
for years to fix some of this stuff
already i mean certainly he inherited a
bunch of messes you know debt and
deficit situation first among them but
you know the idea that somehow at this
point it's not obama's fault that all
these things are going wrong seems like
a weird stance today i mean even just
rhetorically you know setting aside the
policy issue will help all say two
things one is that strategically obama
was in the lead on when you're in the
lead i think it's your job to
not upset the waters because the orders
are good for you and I think that Obama
probably accomplished that task I take
the primary take away from this debate
was that it was boring and that while
Mitt Romney may have had better body
language at time I think that a lot of
people probably too now on and that's
good for Obama on the substantive point
I'll go back to the substance point I
made earlier which is that now is not
the appropriate time to be focused on
Deficit Reduction now is the appropriate
palm get our economy back in order to
spend what we need to spend while it
doesn't cost us anything to do so in
order to in order to bring down
unemployment and then after you dig this
out of the hold that's the time when you
then roll back that's the time when you
bring in the cuts that's the time when
you can stop talk about serious changes
on to our tax policy on the middle class
but before you do any of that you got to
get the time that you finally going and
that doesn't involve all reducing the
deficit what do you think Liz no I sort
of agree with you that it that's that's
been a problem for Obama throughout this
campaign that that although to some
extent it's worked i mean polls still
show that voters blame george w bush
more than they blame obama for the mess
we're in and so I understand why Obama
wants to keep pounding that particular
point because that's part of what's
saving him politically but but you know
right at the beginning of the debate he
kind of teed it up for Romney because he
had that you no explanation where he was
talking about all these things that he
inherited and how bad things were when
he came into office but then it gave
Romney the opportunity to say but yeah
but then look what's happened over the
last four years and and that is you know
the obvious point so that I think to
that extent that also was it was a
better moment for Romney tonight yes
it's a tough sailors have been having a
tough sale with this all year I mean the
whole notion that you know I came into
office essentially saying if I don't
think of it right he himself said more
or less if I don't fix it in four years
I ought to be a one-term president now
he's kind of asking for a do-over the
tough it's a tough sale to make
um he's been making it he's been making
it so far but he really get right he
didn't kind of knock that one out of the
park tonight he didn't I thought I was
trying to listen for his best two-minute
version of why Obamacare is a winner
didn't get it why more jobs have been
created didn't get it I didn't think he
was quick on his feet he could have had
a great comeback to Romney somewhere on
the Big Bird first time we've mentioned
big bird and a half an hour that's going
to be him you know the the the proper
noun at every water cooler I mean that's
the kind of budget cut that Romney tees
up that the amount spent on public
broadcasting is you know about as much
as was spent to light that room tonight
it's a tiny tiny amount of money um yeah
he's wonder we not closing the sale here
with the public broadcasting thing you
know I always wonder how how cynical
that is when Republicans bust that out
of the same with foreign aid right that
you know some of their core voters think
that those two things are much bigger
part of the budget than they are and so
by saying I'm going to cut the
broadcasting are they just sort of
cynically saying like hey I'm a
conservative you should vote for me I
always wonder what's going on there but
I also think that happens in more
serious issues too i was struck during
the education debate about how many
times races at the top was said and I
actually think race to the top is a good
program I'm happy that both candidates
seem to more or less think that it is
good but it's like pathetically small
money it's five billion dollars over
many many years which is nothing even
compared to federal expenditures alone
on education which of course are nothing
compared to state and local expenditures
so the idea that somehow you're going to
be kind of rethinking or reformatting
the status quo with this five billion
dollar program and always strikes me as
sort of first of all laughable but also
annoying because it gives it gives
everybody a way to say like I'm an
education reformer and I'm looking for
these innovative new ways to be without
without really putting any money where
there where
mouths are and you know simultaneously
sending out you know in a quick snap 10
billion dollars to save teachers jobs
which is essentially 10 billion dollars
for the status quo and I think the
upshot of that discussion also again for
most viewers would be that they didn't
see a whole lot of difference between
Romney and Obama I mean I think Romney
really successfully blurred the lines
between himself and Obama on a number of
issues and Obama even did it for him on
Social Security yeah there's no
difference between us I don't think you
know the in fact I think the only issue
where where Obama really may have gotten
some points off of Romney was the
Medicare discussion that was the only
one where I think Obama really
successfully um was able to to portray
Romney's position as different than his
or radically different than his although
as someone who's actually in like a kind
of fundamental state of panic about
entitlements and I suspect we would see
different points of you know how how
serious that panic is even among the
panelists here but um I actually found
it interesting that both candidates were
saying um you know maybe not for people
who are currently retired maybe not for
people who are about to retire but there
are going to be substantial changes to
these programs and you know certainly
they were saying we're going to preserve
them we're going to strengthen them
there's one point when I actually forget
who it was I think Romney said we're
just going to tweak the programs but I
don't think that word means when he
thinks it yeah Dave edit your programs
not a tweak not a tweak not a tweak I
but I do think that there's there's it
was interesting to see both of the
candidates actually kind of saying
they're going to be major changes to
these programs and sort of to contrast
that with the discussion of education
where they were basically saying we're
just going to pretend to make major
changes to these programs that was a big
deficit that's an important thing to
note I think historically that's a big
departure that both sides were saying
that it's also a big departure that
ultimately both of them are talking
about an overhaul the tax code that's
pretty big so maybe maybe the bottom
line here is bad and matter who we vote
for it okay let me let me step in now
we're talk about Medicare on you know
both candidates do have plans Obama's is
mostly loll right now for what we should
do with Medicare Plan it's a lot of it
is in the Affordable Care Act um and
that the problem with Medicare is the
problem with health care in general is
that the nature of health care is that
people aren't going to say no to a
health care expense you know if I have
the choice between a car that costs
forty thousand dollars or a car that's
eighty percent is good that's cost
twenty thousand dollars I by the
twenty-thousand-dollar car but if I have
the choice of the health plan that has
one hundred percent chance of saving my
life or the health procedure that has a
ninety percent chance of saving my life
I take the more expensive plan even if
it's massively more expensive mm-hmm the
hospitals have more and more negotiating
power visa fee patients right now as you
have a proliferation of the buyers of
health care more and more insurance
companies and so there's two ways you
can solve this problem one way is you
can drive down what the hospitals are
charging on patients and what they're
charging Medicare that's Obama's plan is
you get Medicare to drive a harder
bargain with doctors so that the costs
that the government is paying for
seniors to get their care goes down the
other way to do it is to offer less
generous benefits to seniors that's Mitt
Romney's plan and you got to pick one or
the one or the other either you have to
find a way for Medicare to provide the
same benefits for less money or you have
to say fewer benefits and here you have
a very clear difference between the two
candidates on that issue I think we all
might have just reached our wonk limit
right there like well done it actually
that what I thought that was a great
thing about this debate and about your
analysis E and is that it was actually
pretty wonky it was it was nice to have
these two guys get up there and you know
do their best Clinton impressions and
like get into some details about this
stuff you know it wasn't it wasn't
obviously full disclosure but there was
a little something for for the the nerds
like us to chew on and actually we're
going to have to leave it there we are
out of time but thank you you guys for
for participating in our first ever
official post debate google hangout and
thanks to to google for putting this
together we will be back all four of us
or maybe other representatives from our
publications after the next debate to
holler at each other a little more
thanks guys Thank You Katherine GQ hi
and I